obi-wan coming back yeah hello there I
mean I'm one of those annoying people
that have probably asked you about it
for the past five years and your life
safe although there let that's what it's
really good to be cold it's great in
there could we call Tallulah
maybe a will who knows hello there but
I'm like one of those people that have
like asked you about it and Cecily near
like I don't know but I saw an interview
that you were like oh I've been like
lying about this for years well it's
really off it's a really awkward
situation to be in because the studios
and the franchise is they think they
want absolute secrecy and you have to
respect that but the trouble is that
when you're the person being asked you
having to lie about it really yeah and I
don't I don't like that I would rather
not lie about things so when you were
asked about it you have to go well you
know well if they if they want to give
me a call I'm really but I'd be happy to
play the role again and all the while
you would think well we've been talking
about it for a while and and I bet they
don't want me to say that so it's quite
it's quite it was an awkward situation
to be in because they went on for so
long and it started to look like I was
sorry toting from work like it looked
like I was trying to get the job and
then I'd see stuff that people would
send me stuff from online where people
going they better not cast someone else
and they're thinking of someone else and
I was thinking oh do you know what there
isn't somebody else isn't its well
anyway it was an awkward situation for
quite a long time and it's a relief now
to be able to say that we're doing it
yeah because there's has to be like
hundreds of headlines it's like you and
McGregor down to play obi-wan again yeah
yeah yeah exactly it looked like I was
trying to get the job yeah
bless you for not asking any questions
about it some people have been in here
just trying to casually so do you think
so and so we'll be in this story and
they've been trying to get they've been
trying to get the gen on the story yeah
I know better it
you magic like me I don't know about
magic I was called that The Shining can
you talk about your history with The
Shining with Stephen King work when did
you see the shining for the first time I
didn't watch it till I was older I
watched when it came out I was 9 so I
wouldn't have watched it then and then
when I could have watched it and
probably my friends were starting to
watch films like that I was already over
it when I was about 12 I ended up in a
screening of Halloween by accident I
suppose and I it scared them scared me
to death and I just never wanted to feel
that scared again
didn't like it enjoy it and then it put
me off so I didn't ever watch The
Shining because it was by that point had
a reputation of being the most
terrifying film ever made
yes I was like not watching that and
then I guess when I was at drama school
and I was looking at actors who are
great actors to look at their work I was
looking at Jack Nicholson movies and I
thought I'd got a washer shining so I
watched it then and I watched it alone
at night on my own and I thought well
that's how you better do it properly
mm-hmm and then and I was I was blown
away by it and not not a nun surprised
that it wasn't the most terrifying film
ever made because it's a horror movie
but because there's really no horror
movie it's something other than that
it's just something that twists your
brain in a way yeah it's like a very
sinister feeling you get watching it yes
it's like a mood from the from the
opening credits yeah the end of that
something terrible is about to happen
you just feel super uneasy just standing
in I mean the Overlook Hotel you got to
go back to some of those sets you put
your face on the door you're holding an
axe on the stairs I mean what are those
moments feel like for you
you've got to it's odd in a way because
you have to sort of ignore them like the
the there are sort of filmmaker moments
if you like where we're we're we're
remembering the original movie but my
characters not unless it's unless he's
remembering am
of his past in there which of course
Danny had but looking through the door
for instance as an example where I have
to sort of forget that that's so ike
it's it's difficult to but you have to
try and forget that this this is an
iconic moment from The Shining and of
course it's an image of Jack Nicholson
that we see on t-shirts and posters and
all over the world all my life of him
looking through that door and I've got
to know look through it as his son as
Danny and try not to try not to let it
bother me that that I shouldn't be
thinking about the shot really I'm just
thinking about what Danny is thinking
about in that moment and for him that
bathroom that he's looking into was
where he was locked in with his mum and
his mum put him out through the window
and he climbed down through the snow and
escaped and then and he never saw his
father again you know so that that was
what was going on in my mind instead of
just trying to try not to copy Jack yeah
big stick your face in there and be like
Rebecca Ferguson told me she stole
something from said oh yeah did you take
anything I have I have my characters
boots yeah and nice boots they were just
good yeah there was a spare pair you
know that we never got around to there's
always a spare pair in case yeah the end
of the film I I pinched them but I don't
I don't think I took any props or
anything
she took the the copies of the paper
that said all work and no play she yeah
she said she took four of them oh wow
framed um oh wow yeah that's pretty cool
I never thought to do that yeah that was
very weird being in that set though
because when you walked on there there
was the typewriter on the table and the
chair knocked over and it was like Jack
had just gone to his trailer for a
minute yeah back any second it was very
peculiar
with us
[Music]
you